welcome to this video playing plague of
frogs don't sound too nice um okay what
do we get here frogs playing the dragon
is this right okay let's play a more
positional kind of setup not going for
them long castles lines my idea is to
play 495 at the right moment using the
the square huh 95 yeah suddenly can play
that
okay let's let's go here this was the
idea anyway what why does trying to do
is provoke yeah provoke capture and then
using the e-file and play against the
spawn okay so he's attacking on b2 that
probably have no alternative then
capturing so just here probably and okay
my idea now is to double on the e-file
okay now 11 problem is if he goes h-he
didn't age 6 this was what i was getting
it then I don't know where to go with
the sir with this Bishop f5
and maybe I should reroute the night
it's not doing anything on b3 and it's a
little trap here Brooksie 5i can I can
take on f6 leading to a wide advantage
with 94 yeah so we need to need to go
back I'm a foreigner this is hanging
mm I wonder creepy three maybe yeah
maybe not really trying to take it on b7
but maybe I can play a for next and
freeze the queenside now for
now maybe double on the phone
yeah it's just a pragmatic decision in
this you know okay I can take now again
this 94 idea pragmatic decision on to
play the somewhat slower lines and in
blitz because I don't know those low
sharp technical lines with long castles
and this I can I can play without
knowing much of concrete concrete lines
okay nighty forearm is this a good idea
technically I mean the c6 pawn is this
week 94 Quincy 7 rookie one
yeah particular we can just move the the
king or something it doesn't doesn't
really help okay let's just take the e
faun and continued from them so I have
the e-file now I didn't really consider
to take on b7 but okay it's probably
it's not good anyway so what's now night
to be five would be nice ago via f3 he's
going to play a fight I could go nite b
1 a 3 I hope this is not too slow okay
Quincy floor i have this rook e8 check
move which should be trouble for him
I couldn't uncreate lucky a check Bishop
evaders it's not winning material but ok
is trying to prevent this anyway so I'm
trying to get to be five constantly
attacking the pawn and securing the
queenside so yeah but it's got this
Bishop only 50 it's not it's not so
clear all this mmm how the cd56 and
there's still the check I wonder yeah
but I can't they can't take first it
doesn't really doesn't really matter so
take he I takes a fall so i need to go
be three yes but i thought this would be
a bad ending i can i can also go here
this is better better than just
capturing their dear supply f3
yeah this end game is is excellent now
because I have the route to be five yeah
and this this is this is just winning
upon I think he couldn't prevent that
even nights before I text both pawns yet
this Bishop e2 line against the dragon
it's not leading to the kind of
spectacular games but it's a good choice
if you just want a strategical game as
you see it it gets it gets nice once in
a while without any town to play for
black yeah prevent any kind of
breakthrough with age three
yeah and the spawn promotes black
resigns yeah the it's a bit of a
one-sided position it became a one-sided
position i think around here i'm black
is still in in decent shape but then
after the the pawns got messed up it was
it was tricky maybe you should play
Bishop f6e em and just allow the snotty
for thing this is I think even worse
yeah this is this now is very one-sided
he's got chances of course to defend no
no doubt but it's really one sided
position black can never hope to to win
him but he can play it so let's say
something like this put it put this on
me five then maybe try h 4f form and
block block the e-file so this um this
takes some time to to improve by white
maybe can play something like this maybe
be 3c four but be through suffice now
they are not really this is this is the
root for my king I don't want to play
pawn to c4 in the end game be three c4
is a bad structure okay maybe queen here
and then it continues I member probably
need to learn think about this and then
f4 to use the u haul hits it's
defensible for black only after he had
the Queen trade it gets it gets really
bad I could also give give the check
here but this is this a simple and good
I could also take here and take the six
foot
I have preferred that one then this is
now very easy tech technically because I
just wind the pawns alright thanks for
watching